(audience applauds)
- This will not be my campaign.
This will be our campaign, all together.
(crowd cheers)
- [Narrator] Former President Donald Trump
has announced his plan to run
in the 2024 presidential election,
after spending months on
the midterm campaign trail
endorsing a host of Republican candidates.
- Well, I think if they win,
I should get all the credit,
and if they lose, I should
not be blamed at all.
- [Narrator] While Trump remains
a clear leader in the Republican Party,
his appeal has changed since
he ran in 2016 and 2020.
- There's sort of a fatigue
among some Republicans
over Donald Trump and his antics
and what he's left the party with.
- [Narrator] So what has changed
since his first two
presidential campaigns?
And how could those changes
impact his political power and influence
in the 2024 presidential election?
Several of the Republican
midterm candidates
that Trump endorsed and campaigned with
were expected to be a part
of a so-called red wave
that would carry the party to
complete control of Congress.
- Just three days from now,
the people of Pennsylvania
are going to elect
Dr. Mehmet Oz to the United States Senate.
(crowd cheers)
- [Narrator] But the
outcome of the midterms
was weaker than expected for the GOP.
Republicans are poised to
flip control of the House,
but several Trump-backed candidates
in pivotal Senate races struggled,
and the party was unable to
flip control of the Senate.
Candidates who embraced
Trump's unfounded election fraud claims
performed particularly
poorly in the midterms.
Blake Masters, who lost in Arizona
to the Democratic incumbent, Mark Kelly,
aligned himself with Trump,
supporting national abortion restrictions
and claims of 2020 election fraud.
He lost independent voters
by more than 30 percentage
points, according to AP VoteCast.
That, and similar situations
with other Trump-backed candidates,
like Tudor Dixon and Doug Mastriano,
called into question the
power of a Trump endorsement
and whether his brand
has turned away some independent voters.
- There are people who normally
would not talk on the record
talking on the record to
reporters and elsewhere
about, "Donald Trump needs to move on.
It's time for someone else."
- [Narrator] But one
Trump-backed candidate
did perform well among voters.
- We've accomplished more
than anybody thought
possible four years ago.
But we've got so much more to do,
and I have only begun to fight.
- Ron DeSantis's midterm
election victory was so huge
that it has sort of rewritten
how Republicans are looking
at the presidential race.
Suddenly, it's not just Donald
Trump's nomination to lose.
- [Narrator] DeSantis has not
announced a presidential bid,
but Trump has already started attacking
the Florida governor.
- Trump at 71,
Ron DeSanctimonious at 10%.
- [Narrator] DeSantis's victory
comes after some Republicans
have openly called for the party
to move past the former president
and look for a new leader.
- It's basically the
third election in a row
that Donald Trump has cost us the race.
And it's like, you know,
three strikes, you're out.
- There is a growing sense of Republicans
identifying more as members of the GOP,
versus supporters of Donald Trump.
- [Narrator] Following
the midterm elections,
some Republicans have said
that Trump's influence
and endorsement choices
have cost the party winnable races.
- Those who are most closely aligned
with the former president underperformed.
Those who are talking about the future,
who had managed their states
well, they overperformed.
- [Narrator] Other potential challengers
for the Republican nomination
include Trump's 2016 running mate,
former Vice President Mike Pence,
who parted ways with Trump
following the January 6th
attack on the Capitol.
- One thing that will be
really interesting to watch
is how not just voters but the donors,
the big money people, and who
they put their money behind.
A lot of them do want to see someone else.
- [Narrator] Trump has
a proven track record
when it comes to online
and grassroots fundraising,
even after leaving the Oval Office.
Earlier this year, a Federal
Election Commission filing
showed that Trump had more
than $120 million in cash
across his post-presidential
political operation.
But with the presence of
other potential front-runners
in the presidential
race, like Ron DeSantis,
it remains to be seen where
donors will invest their money.
- They are looking to someone else
that can kind of bring the party
a little bit back to where it had been,
a more traditional kind of conservatism.
- [Narrator] Trump also moves forward
amid a host of legal issues,
including civil and
criminal investigations
into his company, Trump Organization,
the January 6th probe,
and a federal investigation
into mishandled classified
White House records.
- [Crowd Chanting] Trump!
Trump! Trump! Trump!
- [Narrator] Trump still remains popular
with right-leaning voters
and allies within the party,
but he now faces new challenges
that could influence his candidacy
ahead of the presidential election.
- He still is the number one
beloved figure in the party
among the voters, the base there.
Now there are cracks in that,
but Donald Trump is
still a very, very strong
and powerful force in the party.
And that should not be overlooked,
even as there are some cracks
and rising stars like Ron DeSantis.
(contemplative music)